ahora vamos a hablar de uno de los
conceptos más útiles en finanzas llamado
el valor actual
si conoces muy bien el valor actual es
muy fácil de entender el significado del
valor actual neto el flujo de efectivo
descontado la tasa interna de
rendimiento y bueno vamos a aprender
todo eso después y muy bien pero bueno a
ver cuál es el valor actual
vamos a hacer un pequeño ejercicio te
puedo pagar 100 pesos hoy
ahora vamos a escribirlo el día de hoy
aquí
te puedo pagar 100 pesos justo el día de
hoy
o te puedo pagar y depende de ti dentro
de un año pero te va a pagar un poco más
te puedo pagar dentro de un año no sé
digamos que en un niño me comprometo a
pagarte 110 pesos
y mi pregunta para ti es y es una
pregunta fundamental en finanzas todo se
va a construir sobre esto cuál de los
dos preferirías tú y esto está
completamente garantizado te prometo que
yo te pago 100 pesos hoy o dentro de un
año te padre de te pagó 110 sin importar
lo que pase si me atropella un camión
pase lo que pase si el planeta sigue
existiendo dentro de un año te pagamos
110 pesos sin ningún riesgo entonces
definitivamente vas a obtener los 100
pesos hoy definitivamente vas a obtener
110 pesos dentro de un año como comparas
los dos y aquí es donde entra en juego
el valor actual qué tal que hubiera una
forma de saber cuánto valen 110 pesos
completamente garantizados en el futuro
qué tal que una forma de saber cuánto
vale en el día de hoy justo el día de
hoy y en términos del día de hoy
entonces bueno hagamos un pequeño
experimento supongamos que puedes poner
tu dinero en el banco en algún banco que
sea libre de riesgo aunque bueno
actualmente poner tu dinero en el banco
no está libre de riesgo pero digamos que
lo pones en el banco más seguro del
mundo por ejemplo la tesorería del
gobierno que bueno o sea son
considerados libres de riesgo porque el
gobierno siempre puede imprimir más
billetes un día vamos a hacer un vídeo
sobre el dinero y la imprenta de papel
moneda y todas esas cosas pero bueno por
el momento vamos a suponer que meter tu
dinero a la asesoría del gobierno que es
básicamente prestarle tu dinero al
gobierno bueno vamos a suponer que eso
está el libre de riesgo y digamos que lo
puedes prestar justo el día de hoy 100
pesos que te voy a dar yo hoy y se los
vas a prestar a un con una tasa del 5
por ciento de interés
entonces completamente libre de riesgo
entonces dentro de un año cuánto va a
valer ese dinero eso valdría 105 pesos
bueno a ver déjame escríbelo siempre sus
por acá
ok 100 pesos y perdón 110 pesos y bueno
esta es una buena forma de pensarlo
entonces saber en lugar de tomar el
dinero dentro de un año directamente sin
10 110 pesos si tomas el dinero hoy y lo
inviertes con una tasa del 5 por ciento
obtendrías dentro de un año 105 pesos
suponiendo que no tienes que gastar el
dinero de hoy ésta es una mejor
situación no o sea si tomas el dinero
hoy sin riesgo y lo invierte si obtiene
105 pesos tienes menos dinero que si me
dijeras dame el dinero dentro de un año
directamente entonces son 110 pesos en
contra de 105 pesos y bueno esa es la
forma de pensar en esto ahora hay que
recordar muy bien que estamos hablando
de cosas sin riesgo una vez que queremos
meterle el riesgo tenemos que empezar a
hablar de distintas tasas de interés
y probabilidades y bueno vamos a llegar
a eso eventualmente pero pues aquí
queríamos empezar con el ejemplo más
puro entonces bueno ya hicieron la
decisión de qué es lo que les conviene
pero también no saben lo que es el valor
actual
entonces hasta cierto punto cuanto vamos
los 100 pesos y dijimos se lo prestó al
gobierno con una tasa de interés del 5
por ciento y dentro de un año me da 105
pesos estos 105 pesos es más o menos lo
que diríamos que vale nuestros 100 pesos
de hoy
entonces qué pasa si lo que queremos
hacer es ir en la dirección contraria si
tenemos cierta cantidad de dinero y
queremos saber cuál es el valor el día
de hoy
entonces veamos lo que hicimos fue tomar
los 100 pesos
y los multiplicamos por uno más del 5%
que es como multiplicarlo por 105
entonces para ir hacia arriba de regreso
lo que tenemos que pensar es cuánto
dinero tendría que tener hoy para que
dentro de un año tenga los 110 pesos y
entonces tengo que divide entre 1.05 y
entonces vamos a obtener el valor actual
cuya anotación es pb de las siglas en
inglés de presentar yo de los 110 pesos
de dentro de un año
110 pesos dentro de un año
y entonces el valor actual
110 pesos en el año
digamos 2009 hay que notar que ahorita
estamos en el año 2008 ojalá que dentro
de un millón de años sigan en este vídeo
pero bueno por lo menos ahorita estamos
en el año 2008 y queremos ver cuál va a
ser el dinero de 110 pesos en el 2009 y
entonces tenemos que dividir los 110
pesos entre 1.05 lo cual es igual a
déjame sacar mi calculadora que es esta
muy buena para hacer estas cuentas pero
bueno a ver borremos todo
y escribamos 110 pesos entre 1.05 lo
cual es igual a 104 punto 76 pesos
entonces esto es igual a 104 puntos 76
pesos
entonces el valor actual de 110 pesos
dentro de un año si asumimos que podemos
invertir nuestro dinero con una tasa
interés del 5% sin riesgo
es 104 punto 76 y déjame cambiar de
color para combatir la monotonía 104
puntos 76 otra forma de hablar de esto
toma el valor de 110 pesos dentro de un
año y aplicarle un descuento con esta
tasa de descuento y la tasa de descuento
es está aquí aumentamos el dinero por
digamos una tasa de rendimiento de 5%
y aquí tenemos que hacer un descuento
equivalente porque estamos regresando
nos en el tiempo y entonces bueno esta
es nuestra tasa de descuento y tenemos
que tomar los 100 pesos y multiplicarlos
por 1 mes nuestra tasa de rendimiento y
para descontar lo desde el futuro hacia
el presente tenemos que dividirlo entre
1 más la tasa de descuento que tiene que
ser el 5% de tasa de descuento
para obtener el valor actual que es lo
que esto nos dice lo que nos dice es que
si alguien está dispuesto a pagar de 110
pesos tomando en cuenta que estamos
asumiendo un rendimiento del dinero el
5% y si alguien está dispuesto a pagar
de 110 pesos dentro de un año y puedes
tomar un 5% de rendimiento sin riesgo
completamente sin riesgo entonces
deberías de tomar el dinero de hoy si el
día de hoy estoy dispuesto a darte más
dinero que el valor actual del dinero
que te daría dentro de un año
déjame borro todo esto
entonces digamos que a ver aquí vamos a
escribir todo lo que tengan que ver con
el día de hoy y en esta columna lo que
tenga que ver con el dentro de un año
entonces bueno acabamos de ver que 110
pesos tienen un valor actual
a ver vamos a escribirlo tve de
presentar yo de sus siglas en inglés
entonces el valor actual de 110 pesos
son 104 puntos 76 pesos y bueno eso es
usted no suponiendo que hay una tasa de
rendimiento del dinero del 5%
ahora lo que esto nos dice es
si tuvieras que escoger entre 110 pesos
dentro de un año y 100 pesos el día de
hoy
te conviene muchísimo los 110 pesos
dentro de un año muchísimo pero te
conviene porque su valor actual vale más
que los 100 pesos ahorita ahora si yo
fuera a ofrecerte 110 pesos dentro de un
año o 105 pesos el día de hoy éste no le
tenemos que aplicar ningún descuento
porque es justo el día de hoy y vale más
que el valor actual de los 110 pesos
dentro de un año
entonces la opción sería escoger los 105
pesos el día de hoy que valen más que
los 104 puntos de 36 pesos es el valor
actual de 110 pesos la otra forma de
pensar en esto es tomar los 105 pesos y
tener el 5% de rendimiento y veamos qué
es lo que obtendría yo tendría dentro de
un año 105 por 1.05 sea tendría 110
pesos con 25 centavos dentro de un año o
sea tendría 25 centavos más y tendría la
dicha de poder tocar mi dinero durante
un año lo cual es muy difícil de
cuantificar por lo que no lo vamos a
meter la ecuación muy bien te veo en el
próximo vídeo